A GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT.
WE HAVE TWO BILLS TO BE HEARD
TODAY.
LAST THE SERGEANTS TO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
UNTIL WE DO WE WILL ACT AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
IT WILL HERE.
THE BILLS THAT WE HAVE A BEFORE
US IN WILL ALSO ASK.
I IF THE SERGEANTS WOULD REACH
OUT. TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUBBY
ARROWS OFFICE.
SO THAT.
HOW THE SENATE MEMBER MIGHT
PRESENT?
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME.
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA WHO IS PRESENT.
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
THREE
.
BUT WE ARE READY SIR WHENEVER
YOU ARE THANK YOU.
I THINK IT'S SHARE OF THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AB TWENTY
NINE SIXTY THREE TODAY.
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REPORT TO CAL OSHA INSTANCES OF
ELEVATED LEVELS OF LEAD AND
WORKERS BLOOD.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE ANY
FINES AND CITATIONS FROM
INSPECTIONS BY CAL OSHA TO BE
MADE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
AS WE ALL KNOW OF THAT COULD
HAVE PROFOUND AND PERMANENT
ADVERSE HEALTH AFFECTS BOTH
CHILDREN AND ADULTS AND AT VERY
HIGH LEVELS LEAD POISONING CAN
BE FATAL. ACCORDING TO THE CDC
NO SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD LEVELS
EXIST.
DATA DERIVED FROM THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS BUT LED
DIRECTLY HAS REVEALED THAT EVERY
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA THERE ARE
HUNDREDS. AND PERHAPS THOUSANDS
OF WORKERS WHO ARE KNOWN TO HAVE
ELEVATED LEVELS OF LEAD IN THEIR
BLOOD.
ONCE NOTIFIED THE PROBLEM BY THE
CDP H. CAL OSHA IS RESPONSIBLE
FOLLOWING UP WITH THESE CASES
HOWEVER THERE'S OFTEN A
DISCONNECT ABOUT WARNING THE
AFFECTED WORKERS OR ADDRESSING
THE EXPOSURE PROBLEM AT THE WORK
SITE. EVEN AND EVEN WHEN
EMPLOYERS REPORT HIDE LEAD BUT
THE BLOOD LEVELS TO CDP H..
ONE OF THE MOST EGREGIOUS
EXAMPLES OF THE LACK OF ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT IS THE EXCITED BATTERY
RECYCLING CLINTON VERNON WHICH
WAS ALLOWED TO OPERATE YOUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
EMIT TOXIC POLLUTION INTO LOCAL
ENVIRONMENT FOR OVER THREE
DECADES.
CAL OSHA PERFORMED LET
INSPECTION UP EXCITE PLANT IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND CPD H.
WAS AWARE OF NUMEROUS LEAD
POISONED WORKERS.
BUT IT WASN'T UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN THAT THE PLANT WAS
PERMANENTLY CLOSED BUT ORDER OF
THE US DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
TODAY WE KNOW THAT THOUSANDS OF
HOMES NEAR EXCITE HAD HAVE
UNSAFE LEVELS OF LEAD IN THE
SOIL.
CHILDREN OF THE PLAN HAVE HIGHER
LEVELS OF LEAD IN THEIR BLOOD.
THAN THEY WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE
BEEN EXPOSED TO.
THIS VILLAGE RIGHT WAY NOT ONLY
HURTS FUTURE AND PRESENT WORKERS
BUT THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN ARE
ALSO BELIEVE HAVE BEEN IMPACTED.
BY THOSE ELEVATED LEAD OF MY
ELDERLY LET PLANTS LIKE EXCITED
UNFORTUNATELY IT APPEARS THAT
MORE AGGRESSIVE ACTION BY STATE
AGENCIES.
COULD HAVE RESOLVED THE ISSUE
MORE RAPIDLY. THEREBY SAVING
HUNDREDS OF WORKERS SOME
EXPOSURE TO THIS TOXIC METAL.
AB TWENTY NINE SKIPPY WOULD
IMPROVE OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS ARE MADE AWARE OF AND
HANDLE CASES OF LEAD POISONING
AMONGST WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WOULD HELP PREVENT REPEATED
INCIDENTS OF LEAD POISONING IN
WORKPLACES.
UP I HAVE WITH ME TODAY IF IF I
COULD MISTER CHAIR OF AS MY
WITNESSES BILL I YOU'D BUT THE
CONFERENCE RECOVERING DIRECTOR
OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR ABOUT
NO WORKING GROUP.
SPONSOR THE BILL AS WELL AS JOE
RUBIN WHOSE.
AN EMMY AWARD WINNING A BASKET
WHERE THAT THE BILL WILL. HAVE
FURTHER I INTRODUCTION OF.
THANK YOU SOME NUMBER FIRST
WITNESS
WHY AM BILL ALLEY รณ WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
SPONSORING THIS LEGISLATION
WE'RE PLEASED THAT MISTER KALRA
WANTED TO GET INVOLVED.
WE WORK ON TOXICS IN YOUR FOOD
YOUR WATER AT THE WORKPLACE AND
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS.
A LETTUCE KIND OF THE TENSION OF
THAT THE NATION AND THIS
LEGISLATURE AND I'M MAJOR WAY
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS WITH THE
FLINT MICHIGAN PROBLEM. AND THEN
WITH OUR EXIDE DISASTER IN THE
LOS ANGELES AREA. LAST YEAR
THERE WERE A COUPLE BILLS ON
BETTER TESTING OF LEAD IN
SCHOOL FOR DRINKING WATER SAFETY
THIS YEAR THERE ARE FOUR MORE
BILLS ABOUT LET TESTING IN
CHILDREN PLUS THIS BILL ON LET
WORKERS. IN ADDITION A PACKAGE
OF SIX BILLS RESPONDING TO AN
INITIATIVE ABOUT LEAD IN PAINT.
SO LET IS A BIG ISSUE AND IT'S.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA SAID
THERE'S NO SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD
BOTH THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION IN THE CDC SAY
THAT.
BOB JOE RUBIN WHAT WILL AN
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALISTS WILL
GO AFTER ME HE'S GONNA TELL YOU
A STORY ABOUT US IS EXPERIENCE
FIGURING OUT HOW. A LOCAL GUN
RANGE A COULD GO FOR YEARS
EXPOSING NEIGHBORS AND THEY
WORKERS THERE TO HIGH LEVELS OF
LEAD AND HE GOT ME INTERESTED IN
THAT STORY HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
BUT WORKERS AND PARDON ME
ANALOGY ARE LIKE THE CANARIES IN
THE COAL MINE. BUT THESE ARE
HUMAN BEINGS BEING AFFECTED BUT
IF THEY'RE GETTING HIGH BLOOD
LEVELS WE KNOW SOMETHING'S WRONG
AT THAT WORK SITE AND THEY CAN
ALSO BRING THE BLOOD THE LEAD
HOME. HAS DUST ON THEIR SHOES SO
LITTLE CHILDREN GET EXPOSED TO
AND CLEARLY AS MISTER RUBIN
STORY.
SUPPOSE THERE ARE GAPS IN LAPSES
IN THE WAY WE OF RESPOND TO HIGH
BLOOD BLOOD LEVELS THAT ARE
REPORTED. I WANTED JUST BRIEFLY
MENTION A COUPLE THINGS THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS RAISED IN THE LAST
WEEK ONE IS THEY SAY THAT THIS
BILL COULD.
RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT PRIVACY
IN TERMS OF HIP OF THE MEDICAL
RECORDS THE BILL DOESN'T CHANGE
ANYTHING. AS IT RELATES TO HIPPA
AND DISCLOSURE ON THAT.
IF THEY SAY READ DIRAC'S THE
CAL OSHA STAFF IMPLYING THAT
THEY'LL BE THINGS THAT WILL BE
MESSED WE THINK THE CALLUSES
STAFF DOES A GREAT JOB IT SAFETY
INSPECTIONS AND SPECIALLY IF
THERE'S CRANES AND. DOORWAYS
THINGS LIKE THAT WE LOOKED AT
THE RECORDS THEY ISSUE FINES
ENFORCEMENT. BUT ON LEAD THEY
SEEMED OF FALLEN DOWN ON THE JOB
SOMEWHAT AND THAT'S WHAT AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE IS ABOUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
YEAH I. PLEASURE TO BE HERE.
I USUALLY COVER THESE KIND OF
MEETINGS AND THE I GUESS IT UP
AT SPEAKS TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
OF. THE IMPACT OF LEAD THAT I'M
HERE FOR FREE EFFENDI TODAY
TALKING ABOUT HOW I GOT INVOLVED
IN THE STORY AND WHAT WHAT KIND
OF THE OVERALL STRUCTURAL
PROBLEMS SEEM TO BE IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN IT COMES TO
PROTECTING WORKERS.
BUT YET MY NAME'S JOEL RUBIN AND
I'M AN INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER.
WORK FOR CAPITAL IN MAINE A
PUBLICATION.
REPORT FOR NPR AND AND OTHER
OTHER PLACES.
AND AND I IT'S I STARTED AS
BILL MENTIONED I STARTED LOOKING
AT THIS ISSUE.
BECAUSE OF A CONTAMINATED GUN
RANGE HERE IN SACRAMENTO. AND
THAT THE GOVERNMENT HAS CALLED
THE MANGAN GUN RANGE AND.
.
THE.
THE RANGE CONTENT WITH BADLY CAN
CAN LIVE INSIDE HUNDREDS OF
TIMES ABOUT FEDERAL LEVELS.
AND ALSO OUTSIDE THE FACILITY IN
THE PARK AND IN NEIGHBORING
HOMES WAS ALSO QUITE
CONTAMINATED. AND I STARTED TO
LOOK IN THIS STORY ONE OF THINGS
THAT I LEARNED WAS THAT.
YEARS BEFORE A CLOSED SYSTEM
LIKE THIRTEEN YEARS PRIOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH BECAME AWARE OF.
VERY SERIOUS LEAD POISONING
PROBLEMS INCLUDING AN INCREDIBLY
LET PUTTING WORKER WHO
SUBSEQUENTLY ACTUALLY DIED. ON
THE MOST LIKELY FROM THE FROM
LEAD POISONING IT IMPACTS
I AM AND WHAT I FOUND JUST
SURPRISING WAS THAT.
THE.
CITY P. H..
DIDN'T INFORM CALLOSUM THAT THIS
WORKER HAD.
IT OUT OF A POTENTIALLY DEADLY
LEVEL OF OF OF LEAD POISONING
AND THE REASON I THINK THEY SAID
THEY. DIDN'T DO THAT WAS
BECAUSE.
THEY PREFER TO WORK WITH
EMPLOYERS AND ONLY AS A LAST
RESORT WOULD.
INFORMED CAL OSHA OF THE
SITUATION.
AND SO THAT JUST YOU KNOW EITHER
SO MANY STORIES AS YOU AS IF YOU
FOLKS NOW.
OUT I TO LOOK AT THAT JUST
STRUCK ME IT'S JUSTIN SOUND
RIGHT SO I STARTED LOOKING INTO
IT. AND WITH THE HELP OF THE US
C. I. ANNENBERG CENTER ON ON ON
ON A ON HEALTH REPORTING. I DID
OF EXTENSIVE PUBLIC RECORD
SEARCH AND LOOK AT THE SITUATION
WITH EXCITE YOU VERY FAMILIAR
WITH EXCITE HIM SURE ON THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TWO THOUSAND IT'S
AND SIXTEEN. APPROPRIATED A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO CLEAN UP THAT THAT
THE NEIGHBORHOOD AROUND THERE BE
SOMETHING LIKE TEN THOUSAND
HOMES HAVE BEEN IMPACTED. I'M
WITH UNSAFE LEVELS OF LEAD.
AND SO.
I'M I KNEW THAT WAS GONNA BE BAD
I MEAN THAT THERE HAD TO BE
SITUATIONS INSIDE THE PLANT BUT
I WAS NOT PREPARED FOR WHAT WE
ACTUALLY FOUND. WHICH WAS THAT
BETWEEN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
AND TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WHEN
THE PLANT CLOSED CD P. H. WAS
AWARE OF.
OVER TWENTY THREE HUNDRED CASES
OF.
BOB DOUBLE OF LOW BLOOD LEAD
TESTS WHICH WERE BASICALLY LEAD
POISONED WORKERS WITH A VERY
SERIOUS LEVEL OF OF OF LEAD IN
THEIR FIGHT. OVER ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE MICROGRAMS PER DECILITER
AND DURING THIS TIME.
.
CALOSOMA KID ONE INSPECTION
WHERE THEY FIND THAT EXCITE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS.
AND SO.
THAT YOU KNOW IT'S JUST
REALLY STRIKING AND YOU KNOW
SOMETHING THAT WAS YOU KNOW WE
FELT WE HAD TO REPORT OF COURSE.
AND.
WHAT WE ARE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE FOUND IS THAT THE
PROBABLY CALIFORNIA'S REALLY A
SYSTEMIC ONE? I'M BECAUSE YOU
HAVE ONE ONE HAND YOU HAVE AN
AGENCY COLLECTING THIS
INFORMATION ANNA ON THE OTHER
HAND YOU HAVE ONE THAT'S. IF
FORCING LABOR LAWS AND THERE'S
ZERO CLARITY AS TO WHEN THAT
INFORMATION MUST BE SHARED.
.
IT'S LIKE YOU KNOW BASS WITH
LIKE A BROKEN GAME OF TELEPHONE.
AND.
WHETHER THE SURPRISING THINGS
THAT I FOUND I THINK WHY THIS
BILL IS SO IMPORTANT.
IS THAT THIS ISN'T THE CASE
EVERY EVERYWHERE ON THE SAME
YEAR THE CAL OSHA FINED EXCITE.
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS.
I.
THE ANOTHER EXIDE BATTERIES
LIKELY PLAN IN FORT SMITH
ARKANSAS WAS FINE SEVENTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER HAVING THE
SAME KIND OF HIGH LEVEL THAT
LEVELS OF LEAD AT THAT PLANT. SO
WHY WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
HERE'S THE HERE'S THAT THE KEY
DIFFERENCE ARKANSAS LIKE THIRTY
EIGHT OTHER STATES HAS CLEARED
LAWS WHICH STATE THAT ANY TIME
WORKERS HAVE THAT TWENTY FIVE.
MICROGRAMS OR HIGHER AYE LEVEL
OF OF OF LEAD IN THEIR BLOOD
WHICH IS THE SAME LEVEL AS AS
ASSEMBLYMAN KALRA HAS IN HIS IN
HIS BILL. I'M THAT DEALT THOSE
THEN I'M QUOTING HERE I'M IN THE
WORK THAT DOES.
SHALL BE CONSIDERED HIGH GRAVITY
SERIOUS AND MUST BE HANDLED BY
INSPECTION
I REPEAT MUST BE HANDLED BY
INSPECTION YET AT EXCITE WE HAD
THESE TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
WORKERS. WHO HAD THIS LEVEL
AND ONE INSPECTION IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT?
AND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLAR
OF FINES SO THIS JUST IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE A KIND OF.
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THESE
AGENCIES ATTEMPT OF GETTING
TOGETHER. AND MAKING SURE THAT
THIS THIS THIS IS REALLY.
REGULATED I'M.
I JUST WANNA CLOSE BY SAYING.
YOU KNOW MY ROLES INVESTIGATION
THAT JOURNALISTS IS TO TRY AND
EXPOSE PROBLEMS AND EXPLAIN
COMPLEX STORIES.
IT'S NOT RIGHT LOS.
AT BUT I HAVE GOTTEN A LEAD PUT
HIM WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
DURING THIS INVESTIGATION. AND I
CAN TELL YOU I'M HAPPY IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS TO GO WITH
SOME DETAILS THAT LEAD POISONING
IN ADULTS IS VERY SERIOUS.
IT IT'S A CLEARLY THE SYSTEM AS
PRESENTLY CONSTRUCTED IN
CALIFORNIA. HAS FAILED THEM.
I'M AND THESE WORKERS DESERVE
THE CALIFORNIA'S BATH WHEN IT
COMES TO PROTECTING THEM.
LIKE YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU OR ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
RENEE BAYARDO ES HERE YOU
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
FROM BROWN INVESTMENT HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS EIGHTEEN
YEAR O. UTILITY WORKERS
MACHINISTS LONGSHOREMEN IPT YOU
LOCAL TWENTY ONE IN ENGINEERS
AND SCIENTISTS OF CALIFORNIA
WEIRD DRIVE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE.
IS THEIR OPPOSITION TODAY.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARTY FISHER HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
AND WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS ANOTHER AGENCY
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
TO DICTATE THE PRIORITIES OF CAL
OF CALLOSUM. AND A CLEAR
CONDITION THAT DOES NOT VIOLATE
ANY LAW AS AN ALLEGE SERIOUS
VIOLATION OF A CAL OSHA
REGULATION.
WHETHER THERE ISN'T A REGULATION
THAT EXISTS WITH THIS OF
VIOLATION AND. A AND THEREFORE
CAN'T BE CITED SO NO CITATION
CAN BE ISSUED FOR A BLOOD LEAD
LEVEL.
OF ANY.
OF ANY LEVEL.
SO ESSENTIALLY THE BILL DIRECTS
CALIPHATE TO ENFORCE A CONDITION
THAT'S NOT A VIOLATION OF ANY
LAW BUT TO TREATED AS SUCH.
KELLER HAS LIMITED RESOURCES
GRANTED THEY DO A GREAT JOB MORE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY DO. BUT
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF REPORTED
BLOOD LEAD LEVELS THAT EXCEED
TWENTY. MICROGRAMS PER DECILITER
AND THIS INFORMATION CAME FROM
THE AUTHORS OFFICE.
IF COLLEGES REQUIRED TO
INVESTIGATE ALL THESE ELEVATED.
BLOOD LEAD LEVELS.
THEN THIS COULD ADD ANOTHER SIX
OR IT MAY BE EIGHT HUNDRED.
INVESTIGATIONS AND INSPECTIONS
TO CALIFORNIA LAW THAT MUST BE
CONDUCTED WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS.
THESE ARE THE INSPECTIONS AT A
RESERVE FOR ONLY THE MOST
SERIOUS AN IMMINENT WORKPLACE
HAZARDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
EMPLOYEES ARE. A KEPT OUT OF
HARM'S WAY SO THIS THIS COULD
CERTAINLY NEGATIVELY IMPACT
CALLUSES WORKLOAD.
WE BELIEVE THAT IF A NEW
REGULATION IS WARRANTED OR
SUGGESTED ARE THAT WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH NEW REQUIREMENTS FOR
BLOOD LEAD LEVELS ARE FOR THE
MONITORING OF BLOOD LEAD LEVELS.
AND WE SHOULD DO IT THROUGH
ESTABLISHED ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES.
THROUGH THE RULE MAKING PROCESS
IN WHICH WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE A THROUGH CAL OSHA.
ANNA KELLER HAS THIS OF
STATUTORY EXCLUSIVE STATUTORY
JURISDICTION OVER WORKPLACE
SAFETY AND THE ESTABLISHMENT
ENFORCEMENT OF WORKPLACE SAFETY
RULES. WE BELIEVE THE CONCEPT OF
THIS BILL IS UNPRECEDENTED NO
AGENCIES SHOULD DIRECT QALISYA
TO ALLEGED VIOLATION WHERE NONE
EXISTS.
OR TO DIVERT OR SKEW THEIR
PRIORITIES WERE IMMINENT
HAZARDS.
SHOULD BE ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU. AT OTHERS WISHING TO
ADD ON IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO I FOUND THOSE WITH THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
REPRESENTING SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ALSO POSED.
AND LAGGED AND ABOUT HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
ARE DISADVANTAGED SOME HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SPECIALTY
CONTRACTORS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING
THAT ON OPPOSITION.
A SCENE NINE WILL TURN TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MEMBERS WITH ANY QUESTION.
IT MISTER JONES SAWYER ARM.
THEY THE OPPOSITION ARM ACOUSTIC
THEIR CLAIM IS.
IF THERE'S NOT A PROBLEM. DON'T
FIX IT UNLESS.
PROVEN BROKEN UNLESS WE HAVE.
.
LEGISLATION HAS SAID THAT BROKEN
OR WE ESTABLISHED NEW CRITERIA.
I'M OF THE OPINION.
.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WAIT.
UNTIL SOMEBODY DIES AT A LOWER
LEVEL.
LET PUT POISONING BEFORE WE GET
INVOLVED. ON BY DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH OTHERS KIN CAN MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION SO CAN COLLECT
CLARIFY OR MAYBE THEY NEED TO
COME BACK AND CLARIFY I IS IT IS
ABOUT.
US CREATED IN THE LAW TO
ESTABLISH A NEW LEVEL OR IS IT.
OR IS IT MORE OF WAIT UNTIL
SOMEBODY GETS SICK.
AND THEN WE NEED TO GO AHEAD AND
CREATE A LAW COULD THIS SEEMS TO
BE A LITTLE MORE PREVENTATIVE SO
I TRIED UNDERSTAND. WHAT THE
ISSUES?
IRVINE I THINK YOUR SUMMER JONES
SAWYER AYE YOU'RE RIGHT THAT IT
IS A
PREVENTIVE MEASURE
IN THAT WE WANTED PREVENT.
A MAJOR A PUBLIC HEALTH. ISSUES
CATASTROPHE IS EVEN A TO OCCUR
AND THE WAY WE DO THAT IS BY NOT
JUST HAVING THE INFORMATION
BECAUSE WE HAVE INFORMATION THE
PROMISE OR NOT. DIRECTING.
THE DEPARTMENT AS TO WHAT TO DO
WITH THAT INFORMATION GETTING IT
OVER TO CAL OSHA. A IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SO THAT
THEY CAN DECIDE THAT WHAT THE
NEXT STEPS ARE THE BACK THE
MATTER IS YOU CAN HAVE YEARS AND
YEARS AND YEARS OF DATA. AND IF
YOU DON'T DO ANYTHING WITH IT
AND YOU DON'T DIRECT.
THE PUBLIC PUBLIC HEALTH AS TO
WHAT TO DO WITH THAT AND CAL
OSHA IS NOT AWARE OF IT THEN
WHAT'S THE POINT OF COLLECTING
THAT DATA AND LET'S KEEP IN MIND
AS WELL. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE.
.
D. I AM THE AMOUNT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING WHAT WHAT WOULD
REQUIRE. OF REPORTING IT A
SETTING APART TO QALISYA.
IS TWENTY FIVE MICROGRAMS PER
DECILITER.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE THE CDC
REVISED REVISES GUIDANCEON
ADULT LED DOWN FROM TWENTY FIVE
MICRONS. TO TEN.
MICROGRAMS PER DECILITER EVEN
LOWER THAN OUR RECOMMENDED
THRESHOLD SO WE COULD EVEN GO TO
A LOWER THRESHOLD I THINK.
I THINK MATCHING ARKANSAS IS A
GOOD PLACE TO START TO ENSURE
THAT WE DON'T ALLOW. LEVELS OF
LEAD TO CONTINUE AT THE WORK
SITE BECAUSE FRANKLY I'M I THINK
MOST EMPLOYERS WITH IF THEY KNOW
THAT THAT'S THE CASE WILL DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. UP BUT GO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT IF THEY HAD
INFORMATION AND CAL OSHA WORKS
WITH THEM TO ENSURE THEY DO
SOMETHING ABOUT.
SO AB AT THE END OF THE DAY THIS
IS ABOUT WORKER SAFETY WORKER
PROTECTIONS BUT ULTIMATELY IT
SAVES EMPLOYERS IN THE LONG RUN
AS WELL FROM HAVING TO. DO A
MUCH GREATER REMEDIAL WORK THAN
IF THEY HAD THAT INFORMATION
EARLY ON AND WERE GIVEN
DIRECTION TO AN INSPECTION TO AN
INVESTIGATION EARLY ON. AND AYE
AND ACTUALLY HELPS EMPLOYERS
MAKE THEIR OF. WORK SITE SAPER
AND ECONOMICALLY A IS ALSO
BENEFICIAL TO THEM AS WELL UP
BUT OF COURSE THE CRUX OF THIS
BILL IS WORKER SAFETY.
NEIGHBORHOOD SAFETY COMMUNITY
SAFETY AND I THINK WE'VE SEEN
FAR TOO MANY EXAMPLES OF.
BECAUSE OF THAT LACK
COMMUNICATION AND TO AND
DIRECTION AS TO WHAT TO DO THAT
INFORMATION. THAT UP WE'RE NOT
DOING OUR JOB AS AS LEGISLATORS
AND AS A STATE TO MAKE SURE
PROTECTING OUR WORKERS.
I KNOW CHAMBER CAME ITEM ONE OF.
DID YOU. CAN ONLY GO OUT PLEASE
COME FORWARD FAIRS COME FORWARD.
AND I AYE MY AND MY DISTRICTS
RIGHT NEXT TO THE EXCISE EXCITE
PLANTS THEN AND IT'S HAD AN
IMPACT ON MY. COMMUNITY MY
RESIDENTS.
AND IF THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
COULD HAVE PREVENTED.
WHAT HAPPENED ELECT SIDE OF?
I'M MORE.
WE SHOULD BEEN DOING THIS AWHILE
AGO SO I JUST WANT TO HEAR. WHAT
YOU'RE?
THINK UNITS AGAIN OR DID I
DESCRIBE IT WRONG.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
SO OUR OUR ISSUE ISN'T THAT
WHETHER.
THERE'S A SAFETY HAZARD HERE ARE
ISSUES WITH THE PROCESS AND THAT
CAL OSHA HAS THE JURISDICTION
OVER WORKPLACE SAFETY IF WE HAVE
AN ISSUE WITH WITH LEAD LEVELS
AND HOW WE'RE TREATING THEM AND
HOWARD TREATING SPORTED A LEAD.
IN THE WORKPLACE WE NEED TO GO
THROUGH CAL OCEAN THROUGH
STANDARD CHANNELS AND HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION. IF THE INFORMATION
THAT.
DID THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IS COLLECTING. IS NOT
GETTING CAL OSHA IN A MANNER
THAT.
THAT IT SHOULD BE AND SO THAT
IT CAN BE DEALT WITH AND AND
REVIEWED AND PROPER STEPS CAN BE
TAKEN. THAT THAT'S ANOTHER
QUESTION BUT TAKEN THE
INFORMATION AND SETTING A LIMIT
HERE WITHOUT. THE SCIENCE BEING
DEBATED THROUGH THE THE MEANS
THE CALIPHATE HAS TO REVIEW
SCIENCE AND THEY DO THEY HAVE A
SPECIAL COMMITTEE IN A SPECIAL
PROCESS. FOR REVIEWING HEALTH
HAZARDS.
US SUCH AS LEAD.
.
THEN WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT
PERHAPS WITH CAL OSHA.
HOW THIS HOW THIS INFORMATION
CAN GET TO THEM AND AND WHAT
WHAT THEY'LL DO WITH IT?
SO I THINK IT'S A IT'S MORE FOR
US IT'S A PROCESS QUESTION WE WE
WE. WE RISK HIGHLY RESPECT THE
WORK OF CAL OSHA AND THEIR
ABILITY TO IDENTIFY HAZARDS AND
DETERMINE THEIR PRIORITIES
WITHIN THE LIMITS THAT THEY.
THEY WORK WITH THEM WITHIN THAT
THE RESOURCES SO. WE. WE WOULD
BE HAPPY TO PARTICIPATE IN A
PROCESS.
WERE WE COULD LOOK AT AT THE
ISSUE AND HOW TO PROTECT OUR
EMPLOYEES BETTER AND HOW IT
YOU'D IN THAT IN THAT REGARD SO
WE'RE NOT DISPUTING.
THE HOUSE HEARD WERE WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PROCESS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT
ESTABLISHING THROUGH THIS.
THANK YOU.
BUT YOU OTHER QUESTIONS SOME
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEN NONE OF WILL GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH.
.
OUR ROLE FIRSTS.
ANTIQUITY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THURMOND HERE FLORA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER JONES SAWYER.
KALRA. MCCARTY. MELENDEZ.
CORMS DOT.
DO YOU HAVE A QUORUM.
WE ARE EXPECT OTHER MEMBERS BUT.
.
TURNING BACK TO THE COMMITTEES
ARE NOT MOVED A BILL. OF SECOND
THE BILL.
I PLEASE CALL THE ROLL HELP
WHICH IF YOU LIKE THE. THINK
THAT THANK YOU I AM YOU KNOW.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU AND
THANKS FOR THE RECOMMENDATION
THINK FEAR QUESTIONS AND THEN
THE MOST MISTER JONES SAWYER.
I JUST SAY LOOK I AYE THERE
THERE IS.
SOMETHING I LIKE TO READ AND AND
AS A PRIVACIDAD.
I WOULD SAY THAT YOU KNOW
TODAY'S FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF.
THE ASSASSINATION OF DR KING AND
OF COURSE HE WAS MARCHING FOR
MEMPHIS SILENCE SANITATION
WORKERS. ID WAS THERE FOR THE
CENTERS WAS NOT JUST.
OF FOR THE DIGNITY OF WORK FOR
WAGES BUT WHEN IT CAME THE
DIGGING YOU WORK IN TERMS OF THE
TOXICITY THAT THEY WERE FACE
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND OF THE PROTECTION OF THE
WORKERS AND SO. WE.
WANTED TO HAVE A WORKER COME UP
HERE AND THE WORKER WAS FRANKLY
TOO SICK TO BE ABLE TO COME
YEARS ON A CLOSE BY JUST
READING.
A MESSAGE FROM THAT WORKER OF TO
THE COMMITTEE BY ME.
OUR NAMES WILL ASSIGN OPEN
RICHARDSON WE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR INTRODUCING A BETWEEN NINE
SIXTY THREE. WE KNOW FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE HOW
IMPORTANT THIS LEGISLATION IS
PROTECT FUTURE AND CURRENT
WORKERS FROM LEAD POISONING
HURTING THEIR LIVES.
OUT HIS ARTWORK AND THE BURN
IMPLANT. IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
NINETIES AFTER A FEW YEARS
WORKING THIS MELTING THEM ALBUMS
ARE EXPERIENCING SYMPTOMS WE NOW
KNOW WERE RELATED TO LET.
EARLY ON IT WAS SMALL THINGS
PROBLEMS ALBUMS HANDS HOLDING ON
OBJECTS LATER THE ISSUES GOT
MORE SERIOUS HAPPENED SPEECH
BECAME SLOWER THERE WAS A
SLOWNESS ABOUT ARMY SEEM DRAIN
AND SLUGGISH.
YOU MIGHT RIGHTLY ASK WHY WOULD
ANYONE IS STILL A JOB LIKE THAT
THE TRUTH IS.
AYE ALLEN SIMPLY NEED A PAYCHECK
AND MAYBE I TRUSTED TOO MUCH
WE'RE FREQUENTLY LEAD TESTED MY
NUMBERS GOT TOO HIGH WILL BE
SENT HOME UPLAND WAS CALLED
LIGHT DUTY THAT WAS MOSTLY
OUTSIDE PAINTING WORK. WHEN
LEVELS CAME DOWN IT WAS BACK TO
THE STARTING ROOM AND WHEN I
LIKE THAT TYPE MONEY THAT THE
COMPANY TWO THOUSAND AD WITH THE
SYMPTOMS GOT TOO BAD.
WE READ THE RECENT BEST
HISTORIAN WAS VERY HURTFUL TO
LEARN THE CALLOW SHARE EXCUSE
THE HIGH LEAD LEVELS AT ALBANY
AND OTHER ACTS AYE WORKERS WERE
CONSTANT EXPOSED TO. PEOPLE
SHOULDN'T BE TREATED LIKE THEIR
DISPOSABLE THAT'S NOT WHAT
AMERICA CALIFORNIA'S SUPPOSED TO
BE ABOUT. AGAIN THANK YOU OF FOR
SUPPORTING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
FOR MAKING CALIFORNIA BETTER
PLACE SO OTHER FAMILIES DON'T
HAVE TO ENDURE THE PAIN THAT WE
HAVE. WITH THAT A RESPECT
ESCRIBO.
THANK YOU OF THIS BILL HAS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION LET US DO
ALL WE CAN TO PROTECT OUR. OUR
WORKERS AND OTHER SOFT FROM LEAD
WITH THAT.
MEN'S UPDATE THESE CULTURAL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMOND AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOW GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER I JONES SAWYER
BY JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NOT VOTING.
NOT VOTING OR NO.
NOT VOTING.
OTHER BILLS OUT CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KAT WILL NOW HERE A FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAMBIADO ON AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTEEN WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUMBIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTEEN. WHICH WILL DIRECT
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO CONVENE
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S TO DEVELOP AMENDED
MEMORANDUM MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING. WHICH WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO ASSIST REGION'S DAMAGED
AND DEVASTATED BY A NATURAL
DISASTER BY SENDING STAFF AND
RESOURCES TO ASSIST IN OUTREACH
AS WELL AS BUSINESS AND CLIENT
SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY AN MOU BETWEEN THE
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S WILL ALLOW FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF BASS LINE
SERVICE EXPECTATIONS ACROSS THE
WORK FORCE SYSTEM AS WELL AS
TRAINING FOR THAT BASS LINE.
IT'S CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN FROM
RECENT FLOODS FIRES AND MUD
SLIDES THERE IS AN URGENT NEED
TO HELP BUSINESSES AND FAMILIES
RECOVER. AND HELP WORKERS WHO
ARE DISPLACED BECAUSE OF THE
DISASTER.
CURRENTLY NINETY PERCENT OF
SMALL BUSINESSES FAIL WITHIN ONE
YEAR IF THEY DO NOT GET SUPPORT
WITHIN FIVE DAYS OF A NATURAL
DISASTER.
NATIONAL DISLOCATED WORKER GRANT
FUNDS WHICH ARE FEDERAL FEDERAL
FUNDS. AND OUR DISCRETIONARY
CONTAIN TAKE MONTHS TO ARRIVE
THE GRANTS CAN PROVIDE FUNDING
TO CREATE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THAT DISPLACED
WORKERS TO ASSIST IN CLEAN UP.
REPAIR AND RECOVERY EFFORTS AND
TO LEARN ON THE JOB SKILLS WHICH
MAY HELP THEM IN THE FUTURE.
A LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION THIS
NECESSARY TO ALLOW THE FORTY
FIVE LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARDS TO
COME TOGETHER AND UNDER ONE
UMBRELLA OF MUTUAL AID SO THAT
THEY CAN LEVERAGE RESOURCES IN
TIMES OF NEED. CURRENTLY THERE'S
NO MECHANISM FROM FOR THEM FROM
OUTSIDE THE DISASTER AT AREA TO
PROVIDE STAFF AND SUPPORT TO AID
THE BUSINESSES FAMILIES AND
WORKERS THAT ARE AFFECTED.
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTEEN PROVIDES
A MECHANISM TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITIES WHEN THEY MOST NEED
IT.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS ERIK FLORES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM ERIK
FLOWERS IN THE POLICY DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE THE
NONPROFIT MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS THE
FORTY FIVE LOCAL WORKFORCE
BOARDS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
FEMA STATISTICS SHOW THAT NINETY
PERCENT OF SMALL BUSINESSES FAIL
WITHIN ONE YEAR OF A NATURAL
DISASTER IF THEY DO NOT GET
ASSISTANCE WITHIN FIVE DAYS OF
THAT DISASTER. AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTEEN IS NECESSARY TO ENSURE
THAT THE DEVELOPMENT OF A MUTUAL
AID AMMO YOU IS MADE AND KEPT
THE PRIORITY AMONG WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
THE BILL IS DESIGNED TO ADDRESS
THE NEED FOR CLARITY SURROUNDING
MUTUAL AID ASSISTANCE ACROSS
LOCAL WORKFORCE JURISDICTIONS IN
THE EVENT OF WORK FOR SPORTS
RESPONDING ACROSS BOUNDARIES TO
NATURAL DISASTERS.
WHILE LOCAL WORK FOR SPORTS HAVE
A HISTORY OF REGIONAL WORK AND
COLLABORATION DURING TIMES OF
NATURAL DISASTERS THERE'S NEVER
BEEN CLARITY ON WHAT REGIONAL
ACTIVITIES LOCAL BOARDS MAY
UNDERTAKE.
MUTUAL AID AGREEMENTS ARE USED
EFFECTIVELY BY HOSPITALS AND
FIRST RESPONDERS BUT HAVE NEVER
BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
CLARITY OF WHAT IS PERMISSIBLE
UNDER STATE AND FEDERAL LAW.
AS NATURAL DISASTERS HAVE BECOME
CALIFORNIA'S NEW NORMAL WE MUST
LEVERAGE THESE EXISTING
PARTNERSHIPS TO ALLOW SWIFTER
RESPONSES TO DEVASTATION.
WHILE LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARDS
BUSINESS SERVICE REPRESENTATIVES
ARE PROFESSIONALS TRAINED TO
PROVIDE TARGETED SERVICES TO
BUSINESS OWNERS TO HELP KEEP
THEIR DOORS OPEN. OFTENTIMES
DISASTERS SUCH AS LAST YEAR'S
FIRES IN THE NORTH BAY OR MONTHS
HE DOES MUDSLIDES PREVENT THOSE
WORKERS FROM REACHING THOSE
AFFECTED.
IN CINEMA COUNTY THE BURNING OF
THE HILTON CINEMA RESULTED IN A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PEOPLE
SUDDENLY WITHOUT THEIR
LIVELIHOOD.
YOU COMBINE THAT WITH OTHER
BUSINESSES THAT ARE AFFECTED THE
LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARD IT WAS
QUICKLY OVERWHELMED.
ENSURING MUTUAL AID COULD MEAN
CRITICAL DAYS BEEN SHAVED OFF
RESPONSE TIMES AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL BOOTS ON THE GROUND
AT A TIME WHEN OUR REGION NEEDS
ECONOMIC INVESTMENT IN
REBUILDING THE MOST.
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTEEN IS
SPECIFIC AND TARGETED IN SCOPE
IT IS NOT A STATE MANDATE BUT
RATHER DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE FROM STATE AND LOCAL
POLICY LEADERS ON WHAT IS AND IS
NOT AN ALLOWABLE ACTIVITY UNDER
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW. WHEN
LOCAL BOARDS WHICH TO UNDERTAKE
MUTUAL AID EFFORTS TO HELP WITH
CRITICAL TASK OF DISASTER
RELIEF.
CURRENTLY THERE IS A NEED TO
TACKLE TEMPORARY WORKERS AND
DISPLACED WORKERS TO LOCAL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE SEEKING WE
ARE. RECOVERY SERVICES.
ACCORDING TO FEMA AGAIN FORTY TO
SIXTY PERCENT OF BUSINESSES
DON'T REOPEN AT ALL AFTER A
DISASTER. IS MADE WORSE BY THE
FACT THAT THERE IS NO MECHANISM
FOR LOCAL AREAS TO PROVIDE STAFF
AND SUPPORT THAT COULD MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOUSANDS OF
JOBS AND BUSINESSES BEING SAVED
OR LOST.
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTEEN WILL
ENSURE THE STATE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD CONVENES THE
FORTY FIVE LOCAL WORKFORCE PORTS
SO THEY CAN JOIN TOGETHER AND
LEVERAGE RESOURCES IN TIMES OF
NEED. ANIMAL YOU WITH THE STATE
BOARD AS A PARTNER WILL ALLOW
FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT OF PEACE
LINE SERVICE EXPECTATIONS ACROSS
THE SYSTEM. AS WELL AS TRAINING
FOR THAT BASS LINE AS WELL AS
PRIORITIZING WORK FOR SERVICES
AND DISASTER RELIEF.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT.
A SCENE NONE LOSER ANY
OPPOSITION.
SO YOU KNOW OPPOSITION RETURNED
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SOME.
THIS MOTION A SECOND A SOME MEN
CALLER HUSBAND MOVEMENTS NAM I
SUPPORT THAT AND I APPRECIATE
THE BILL BECAUSE I THINK THAT.
IT'S GOOD TO DO THESE THINGS
WHAT WHEN WE'RE NOT IN THE MIDST
OF A DISASTER.
AND SO I I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE HURDLES
TO GET PEOPLE TO HELP OTHER
PEOPLE WHICH WE SEE WITH MUTUAL
AID WITH WITH FIRE AND WHAT HAVE
YOU. THIS GREAT OPPORTUNITY AND
OTHER SERVICES THAT.
THAT BEACON WOULD REALLY HELP
TO ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE SHORT
TERM TRAUMA THAT A LOT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING THROUGH
DURING A DISASTER SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH IN THE BOOK FORD THANK
YOU. CLICK HERE SIMILAR LENDERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST
WANTED THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD.
I THINK WHEN WE SEE NATURAL
DISASTERS LIKE THIS THAT TAKE
PLACE AND ALL OF THE NEWS THAT
SURROUNDS THEM AND ALL OF THE.
DIFFERENT REQUEST AT COME
FORWARD OFTENTIMES. ELEMENT OF
REBUILDING GETS LOST IN THE
SHUFFLE AND PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT
ON THE JOBS THAT ARE LOST THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DISPLACED AND HOW
THEY CAN I READ. BUILD NOT JUST
THEIR HOME.
BUT THE YOU KNOW DIRT DIRT
COMMUNITIES IN THEIR IN THEIR
EMPLOYMENT AND IT'S JUST I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRING IN
FOREIGN HAPPEN IS PART. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS.
A SCENE NONE THIS.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE SPECTRUM
THE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
CAN'T IMAGINE HOW DEBILITATING
IT MUST BE TO LOSE A JOB OR
BUSINESS ON TOP OF THE LOSSES
THAT OCCUR IN DISASTROUS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL CREATIVE
WAY TO SUPPORT. OUR BUSINESSES
AND FAMILIES IN OUR STATE THIS
BILL ISN'T TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THING I'M VERY
MUCH CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE JONES SAWYER LACKEY
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA I. MCCARTY MELENDEZ
LINDA'S I.
IT'S UNANIMOUS THE BILL'S UP
MIDDLE A MUCH PRESENTED TO YOU.
OF THIS CONCLUDES THE BILLS THAT
WE HAVE FOR TODAY WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN BRIEFLY.
FOR MEMBERS WHO NEEDS TO ADD ON
TWENTY NINE FIFTEEN MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE.
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY